my channel is sponsored by bespoke post
which means i'm gonna put an ad from
them in the middle of this video rather
than youtube randomly selecting one and
putting it wherever it wants thanks to
bespoke post hello everyone it is the
last sunset of summer and i had to come
to venice beach um just walking distance
from here to get a clover test so that i
can go shoot some stuff with fun house
this week so i thought that i would come
look at the sunset
the first time i ever came here
i found it so weird
how much sand there is
the beach
is so big
but they are pretty sunsets naturally my
iphone is not doing the best job of
picking it up and that's
santa monica pier down there
which that one the first time that i
came here this beach just makes me go oh
it's gta 5. but while i'm sitting here
enjoying the sunset in any case i wanted
to talk about
my makeup um
i posted about this on instagram and get
a lot of questions and i have made a
video about it once before but i did
something a little bit differently this
time and i really like it so in case you
can't tell uh right now i do not have
any makeup on my skin
all my freckles out in all their glory i
have eyeliner that is a day old but
that's it
hmm
these brows
are
tattoos and so are my lips
you may have heard of microblading
before i made a video about it um my god
it just keeps getting prettier
i made a video about um
like maybe the third time that i got my
eyebrows micro bladed because you do
have to get it done repeatedly this time
they are not actually micro bladed micro
bleeding
is an extremely painful process where
they draw tiny little like scalpel lines
into your brow and then they fill them
with ink so it basically emulates the
look of a hair is the intention a lot of
people really like it i really liked it
the issue that i had with it though was
that the first time i had it done they
went a little bit too deep
and
it meant that when the ink faded because
anything you put on your face or i think
your hands they say in terms of tattoos
is going to fade faster than it would in
other places you just touch your face so
much all the oils the amount you wash it
and i think they use a different kind of
ink as well it would fade to like pink
you could look like i had pink lines in
my eyebrows so we've done something
different this time and i think it looks
way nicer this is only day three um
which means it will get lighter they
won't always look like this but we did
something that is called shading in the
industry i believe they call it pixels
where
i actually just have like a bunch of
tiny dots in the right shapes
and it's an alternative to putting
makeup on i do it because uh i hate my
eyebrows um
whenever i make a video that's about
anything appearance-based i always want
to say it's not for anyone else i don't
feel like anyone's ever picked on me for
my eyebrows it's nothing like that
it is entirely just
i hate them and i don't like putting
makeup on so
well that's not true i do like wearing
makeup makeup is fun but i don't want to
do it in the morning you know i work in
game development these days i write
behind a computer for a living basically
i just don't have to do anything i just
walk out because my eyebrows were a
thing that i would almost always do just
because they suck really really sparse
like they're like old lady browsers how
i feel about them so yeah it's not for
anyone else there's no like oh you're
beautiful no matter what situation i was
never worried about that just a thing
that makes my life easier because now i
don't have to put any makeup on my
eyebrows this process is um i believe
little tiny dots
all over your eyebrows they will give
you like a little line first an outline
of what they're going to shape in so you
can confirm that you like it put numbing
cream on you and then they put little
tiny dots of ink into your eyebrows to
make it look like it has that filled in
shape they're also fading it slightly
different you can see this one's faded
also a note is that um you can see this
red mark on this
eyebrow here um this eye is swollen so
they kind of look like different shapes
right now
and uh if you were wondering
yes it does hurt look at this sunset
though
it's just
so pretty
you can't see the pink on the camera
maybe you can see it a little bit better
over there
beautiful my god so after you have it
done it'll get really dry you have to
put um
basically petroleum jelly and nothing
else on your eyebrows shouldn't put any
makeup around it so that there's no
infections because you do have tiny cuts
on you and this is how they should stay
i mean you guys will see over a period
of time as i upload more videos if they
change it all but it is wonderful
the new thing though that i got done
which um even family members were like
what does this mean is my lips
these are
tattooed
and when i first got it done they were
like bright red i looked like a complete
clown like just ridiculous it was like
red all over my mouth as well from the
ink
it is a somewhat similar process where
they
tattoo your entire lips
uh
a color that would be you know we agreed
upon the color i want to be clear that
this is not lip liner i've not done
anything to make my lips look any bigger
nothing like that it's just like
basically
um if you were to put
like a slightly colored chapstick on is
how your lips will look all the time the
reason that i did this one is actually
just because my friend who does my
eyebrows texas dollar so he is
absolutely wonderful and i won't leave
him linked in the description i think
he's fantastic at what he does had
posted on his instagram was like got
these new lip colors want to try them
out and i was like i'm down to try it um
it was not anything
there was not anything i was trying to
correct about my lips nothing like that
uh
i'm just like sure why not it is time to
talk about bespoke post bespoke post is
a monthly membership club delivering
awesome boxes of top shelf goods from
under the radar brands so first things
first i got the terror box which comes
with this ridiculously beautiful knife
i've never owned a cool knife before
i've been using this thing to open boxes
even though i imagine it's supposed to
be used for gardening i did also get
their alchemy kit which is all about
cocktail making it comes with two
weighted shaking tins a bar spoon with a
muddler japanese style [ __ ] a hawthorn
strainer and some slow crafted bitters
the thing that i've been using the most
though is the two-inch square ice cube
tray i also realized that i could get
creative with it if i wanted because
it's made from silicone you can kind of
squish it when you put it in your
freezer against other stuff and get like
weird shapes out of it but the thing
i've gotten the most use out of is this
weekender bag i guess all the bags that
i currently use that are in this shape
have zips at the top which it hadn't
even occurred to me means that they can
be really hard to close they actually
said on the website that the style was
originally used by stonemasons to hold
their tools to construction sites but a
durable cotton canvas metal hardware and
reinforced frame these thick leather
straps which i really like removable
nylon webbing shoulder strap and
interior pockets every month they have
different products to show their members
outdoor gear bar wear home and kitchen
goods clothing and more a very helpful
thing is that you get to preview your
box before it's shipped you'll get a box
assigned to you at the start of each
month based on your preferences and
before it's shipped you'll get a preview
of what comes inside your site if you'd
like to keep it swap it out for a
different box or skip the month entirely
for no charge you only pay for what you
want and you can cancel your
subscription at any time to get 20 off
your first box go to the link in the
description and enter alana 20 at
checkout and yeah they went from
you know
a regular looking lip to bright red to
four days later this kind of watermelon
color
they will still fade more over the next
six weeks but
it basically just looks like you always
have like i said colored lip balm on or
like a tiny bit of lipstick it's not
dark enough really to look like lipstick
um or won't be in the long run now i
feel like you could argue that this
looks lipsticky
but yes it doesn't change the shape of
your lips or anything i guess you could
say it gives you a slightly more defined
border
because it's making the color a little
bit more even but it's not a solution
for the girls who want to like go
uh kylie jenner and look like their lips
are oversized i already have pretty
significantly sized lips i always find
it really funny actually that um
i used to get picked on in school for
having really big lips
and now
because the trend is to have filler and
i do not have filler
i don't feel like i have big lips
anymore like i used to get picked on for
it
and now they're so big
that my lips aren't even considered big
anymore it's very very weird but yeah
basically it just like shades the color
a bit i guess and i do think it's really
pretty i really like it um
and yeah the effect is basically that i
am very lazy i do like to look after my
skin and i don't tend to put any makeup
on my actual skin i'll only put it on my
eyelids like i do have a skincare
routine that uh i put effort into
because my skin used to suck until a
friend we went away for christmas
my friend steimer who some of you might
know from what's good games and she just
like taught me a bunch of [ __ ] and i was
like i should be nicer to my skin this
is not a bad idea
so i do like my moisturizer and all that
um and do put a lot of effort into
being nice to my skin and trying to
you know eat well drink a lot of water
general health but this means even less
[ __ ] that i have to do if i'm going out
i don't feel the need to do anything
ultimately what i'm trying to tell you
is i'm really lazy but then i also like
the way that it looks so my lips are
still a little bit sore moving feels a
little bit weird it's still like a
little bit like tense kind of like
does feel a little bit strange
they have peeled a bunch um
which is just like you know just like
having dry lips and it's the same thing
i'm just putting petroleum jelly on them
i'm cleaning them every day with a
solution that texas gave me or i just
have to like put this i guess it's
antiseptic stuff on them and then wipe
it off and yeah i think they look really
good i really like it
obviously from my perception the sunset
hasn't changed because i'm not looking
at it constantly but i wonder what it'll
look like from the start of this video
to the end do you reckon i should go
visit michael
to santa it's his therapist actually
isn't it his therapist lives like there
somewhere i think
the sky is also a lot pinker than i feel
like the
camera is giving a credit for me this
angle is the prettiest
ridiculous
i also do really love that you can just
sit alone on this beach because there's
so much space you know
it looks like
nobody is here
i certainly had a weird summer because i
was in australia for half of it trying
to leave um
so i only got like a month and a half of
summer this year and it is my favorite
season
i have not been to this beach even once
and i wonder what it'll be like this
time next year i don't know why i'm
sentimental about this summer
specifically usually i'm not well still
in a weird place you know
but uh yeah i just wanted to make this
video because i know people find it
interesting they did in my last video it
funnily enough the
video where i talk about my
uh eyebrow tattoos from the first time
oh for the record i do need to say they
don't remove my eyebrows i still have
full eyebrow hairs right like
the camera doesn't really pick that up
you can kind of see it i'm hesitant to
touch them too much um they don't shave
your eyebrows off this is just like
shading around the hairs basically uh
but the first video that i made about
getting my eyebrows microbladed again
they are now shaded not microbladed and
i think that i really prefer it has the
highest
male
audience of almost my entire channel
which i found really interesting when i
said that the first time people were
like what but yeah obviously old dudes
watch your channel and i was like no you
don't understand what i'm saying is that
that video specifically has less women
than all my gaming videos do because i
do have a bunch of women who watch my
stuff of course i do um and it's funny
that i make something female centric and
the women don't click on it as much
the men do and i imagine that'll happen
for this one as well maybe the other
and it was all because i think so many
dudes were really interested in what the
process is
and to have somebody explain it who is
not like a beauty channel or something
so people were like what is this and men
can do it too for the record you uh you
can i think you have to be really
careful if you're a guy is what texas
was saying to make sure that you would
go to the right artist if you have
patchy eyebrows you don't like your
eyebrows or something you have to pick
the artist more carefully because
sometimes they accidentally give men
really feminine looking brows and then
they'd have to get them removed which he
said he has done a few times with people
as well
but uh
yeah it seems like i i think it's that
having someone who obviously is a
personal channel but someone who makes a
bunch of gaming content make a video
about something that guys might have
been curious about means that the click
rate for men is higher here whereas the
women on my channel probably aren't very
interested in it and would prefer to
watch me do let's plays generally women
watch the let's plays the most where
women who are interested in makeup stuff
just go to like beauty channels i don't
know i thought it was super interesting
it's actually way darker than the camera
is making it look
right now getting a little bit chilly
out here
yeah i just wanted to
invite you guys to the beach with me
um i knew i was gonna sit here anyway
and just stare at it and talk about
something that people ask questions
about so if you have any more questions
let me know otherwise i will leave a
link in the description to where you can
find
texas and you can see way more examples
of the stuff that he's done but i'm very
happy with it i think it's awesome
really enables my lazy ass so i don't
have to put anything on my face other
than moisturizer and sunscreen but uh i
get to head home because venice beach if
you didn't know if you're not from l.a
gets very unsafe as it gets dark a lot
of drugs i believe taking place on these
beaches
um and i am obviously here by myself
thank you all for watching i hope this
was interesting i i'm planning to make
more vlogs
um do more stuff like this and if it
times out i believe this video will have
a bespoke post to add in the middle of
it i'm not actually sure if that will
happen or not but if so check the link
in the description to find more about
this blog post
um but otherwise i'll see you guys next
time bye